in Algeria Abdul Majid aboon has been
declared the winner in Thursday's
presidential vote preliminary results
show that he won 58 percent of that vote
his closest rival at Dhaka dabangg
kareena came second with just 17 percent
of the vote results show there will be
no need for a runoff but less than 40%
of voters turned out for the poll with
millions boycotting calling it a sham
well let's dig into this with Dalia
gonna me as Beck she is an Algerian
political analyst and a resident scholar
at the Carnegie Middle East Center and
she joins us now on skype from Beirut
Dalia can an election with such a low
turnout have any real legitimacy no of
course not and this is obvious you know
Algerians have been refusing this
election for the last nine months since
the beginning of the peaceful and Civic
protest and yet the military the
political military leadership went with
it
despite the refusal of a majority of
Algerians
well one thing we made sure the boon is
not going to have any concrete any real
with legitimacy and this will put him
under a lot of pressure pressure from
the people who have been escalating in
their demands and asking for more and
more and pressure under the military who
brought him to power dolly let's start
with the protesters presumably they're
going to continue taking to the streets
the unrest will continue indefinitely
where did the protesters go from here
yeah well this is the big question
because our Julianne's have been taken
up to the street for the last nine
months peacefully civically we need to
insist on that it's really something
major that they achieved but the
question now is where they are going to
to to to continue to him so to head
sorry so I do believe that the popular
movement is
showing any signs of abetting and
actually Algerians are going to continue
to take up to the street and to
demonstrate now we do know you know in
sociology that no social movement can go
on like that endlessly so I do believe
that the hawk the popular movements
needs a minimum of institutionalization
meaning they need to appoint people from
the HERA
to represent them and to negotiate with
the with the leadership
well Dahlia as you were saying it's the
army and specifically one general who
wields a huge amount of Peron Algeria
what is the next move for the military
leadership and for him and given that
this election result has very little
legitimacy both at home and abroad
that's true the political military
leadership is faced with three options
the first option is to continue you know
to ignore the demands of the popular
movement and to you know to to to rely
on the exhaustion of the movement the
second option would be to use coercive
measures seriously crackdown on the
population and the third option would
which would be the wiser would be to
negotiate seriously with the popular
movement and sit on the table and you
know go on a serious tradition towards a
more healthy civilian military
relationships in Algeria
well we'll be watching very closely to
see what they do choose Dalia Ghanim
Yazbeck and Algerian political analysts
they're speaking to us from Beirut Thank
You Dalia